oh God yes that's the ticket that is the
stuff that is the stuff how you feeling
I feel energized B12 up focused full of life and
ready for another 10 to 12 hour day quenched and
fueled is what we feel here with G fuel they are
uh literally how we survive uh these long days of
having bright lights and cameras and attention
and faces and focus on us OG fuel so much love
one of the best ways to support the channel
is by getting yourself some g-fill using our
special promo code I want to keep this partnership
forever to channel out more than any other brand
deal we ever had in our lives because frankly
trailers at 6 a.m Show's dropping at midnight
it's a 24-hour situation also another thing that
helps out the channel is leaving a like on this
video yes yes so we know that you like this video
and that helps us know what you want us to watch
in this video or are we watching we're watching
RoboCop too oh my God because people recommended
it very specifically because we said we would
not watch it now we're here watching we with
the entire video going like I want to preserve
this experience and then all the comments were
like no no I'm I've never seen even a moving
frame I have no clue what this one's about I
knew they rebooted it I knew that at some point
he left Peter Weller and now I'm about to find
out he is in this one and why and how and if you
want to watch this full experience please check
out the patreon where these super sexy rejects
get to watch this front back beginning to end
with no cuts to Full Experience you can see
our resting watching faces as we RoboCop so
check it out over there and also over there Greg
and John watch several other shows exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included without further ado let's RoboCop too
[Music]
okay yeah this is a different
movie you can already tell I'm
so in the little little drums Kevin Bacon hair
[Music] looks like a PSA
whoa what is happening oh yes [Laughter]
no way no need to trouble the police
it is a PSA it's a commercial it's a commercial
and it won't even run down
your battery thanks John Glover
[Music] I love this the Surgeon General is dead
gunned down 20 minutes ago by militant addict of
the deadly designer drug nuke the greatest
Health threat facing our nation oh we're
going to deal with drugs this time oh early
90s the most addictive narcotic in history
a plague wow the news does not censor here
nope not Frank Miller's Universe people want
paradise and they will have it the assassination
is the latest Act of terrorism by Kane following
the firebombing of a drug treatment Clinic
terrorists or misunderstood just wants Paradise
what are you gonna do ocp cut out salaries
40 and cancel our pensions God knows why but
they want this straight okay so they haven't
dropped the commentary no not at all so far
what happened wow
[Music]
Detroit's not great that Homeless lady was walking
around with all that [__]
she just mugged another lady
real Circle of Life situation
I hope this movie is just
whatever's been stolen just
keeps getting passed away
[Music] all right come on come on [Music]
this definitely reminds me of Dark Knight
Returns like we'd like to talk about the TV
last time but also the bad guy talking to
the camera and like planning his stuff and how
bad Gotham's got oh sure sure where's the Bulls
this one's definitely a lot
more cheesy immediately [Music]
hey this guy always played this kind of
role yeah this guy's like the face of this
it is an interesting time to set it where
cops are on strike so there could be like
it's like The Purge getting us in
the streets or something the first
movie had that at the end where it was
threatened remember I think they set it up
[Music]
was there anyone in that car
and did not see a driver there
non-descript villain of the 80s and 90s he's gone
well they got set pieces down [Music]
shot through the flickering oh when humans
are on strike machines will do the jobs
did you slim down buddy you got a little leaner
moving great peace officer [Music] take it over
creep he's a little brighter in per player Luke
where is it made it's not
mine man I told you I'm clean
[Music] the music with that walk
is a choice [Music] Peter Weller
did not return for a third RoboCop it's like
a Schumacher world now oh yeah I could call
all right we've never opened credits yet
right this feels like the 90s oh yeah it's
weird this one feels dated versus the
last one which was the 80s but didn't
feel they didn't yeah it feels like super
specifically 90s who directed this uh I
heard Irvin kirschner is director of Empire
Strikes Back director to this yeah all right
even that live Terminator soundtrack
nice speaking of Terminator instead of
the reach through just the one punch
what a silly shot oh that's great hahaha
that was hilarious Sasquatch walk into frame
date mode
Daddy Mode Robo baby oh he's
definitely got way more like
ornate branding he's only got 90s
branding RoboCop this is a must
oh protect the baby everyone aim for
his body shoot everywhere but his face
man be shot he's got more
personality that was cool
why do I feel like this teenage
boy is going to be important I
feel like he's a sidekick yeah he's
the Lone Wolf and Cub storyline yeah
hey she's back [Music]
they're even acting differently like
they're moving I don't know it's weird
there's some things like different oh yeah I
mean it's it's lost it's great grounded real
but I was prepared for that it's fair
it's just weird that even emotion I'm
like this looks different [Music] kids
and tons of stuff I think I can't shoot
a kid can you whoa oh the one smart kid
the one smart guy in the movie of anyone
oh oh my God it's gonna be a father-son
story Lone Wolf in Cub with a kid
[Applause]
no [__] from either one of you plot
trajectory is he gonna Ricochet it off the door
we can't have that yes smart
do we get to meet his family oh yeah they would
be alive oh very much so I think this takes place
mere months after the first my impression was
they were dead for some reason just left him
[Music]
do you see my RoboCop movie would be
a psychological Thriller about RoboCop
cracking and wanting his family back I've
been mine about the internet he'd have an
existential crisis about whether Humanity was
worth saving or not Allah thematic I would go
he'd become psychotic and wants to kill
whoever her his wife is now sleeping with
it's a Revenge Thriller yeah I want
a man versus self versus machine
see it would be from her perspective
all this creepy stalker stuff oh it's
like Jaws robocops jaws you have any idea
what you're doing to that poor woman take
a look at her file hmm Mrs Murphy is
bringing suit against ocp my name is
Tom Delaney I'm representing oh this is
an interesting plot spying on her trying
to make her think her husband is still alive
she's barely started to accept the loss oh
that is interesting do you think you could ever
be a husband to her what can you offer her not
gonna lie guys I love this plot idea yeah this is
a great name I'm reinvesting are you Alex Murphy
no are you human you are simply a machine oh
no say No I um oh that loss of Soul oh wow a
vacant stare hey this is a good character setup
for Murphy what is he what is his identity what
is it what is humanity for this guy that was the
movie I wanted a minute ago no I'm getting it yeah
before Oh this is tragic
Alex don't you remember me
it's not how I expected her to
behave touch me he wants to be human
they made this to honor him to honor him
your husband is dead I don't know you
gotta reject it I mean it's ultimately what is
best for her we saw that transition in him but
he sacrifices his own soul for this thought all
communication systems were the same I tried to
save the company a few bucks it took two days to
download specs from Cleveland I lost the account
it's a hell of a commercial
I had missed the commercials commercials are
amazing we're taking Detroit privately you
deliberately undermined our credit that
was the easy part prick do you know how
many people are dying that they murder us if
I was you to say nothing further it might be I
okay so they're shining more of a spotlight this
time on the dangers of capitalism over Humanity
it's that good sequel escalation of like they got
away with it now they're this far I love how they
are keeping them as bad guys even though RoboCop
saved him in the last movie he learned nothing
the name of the title of the
movie is the thing oh this is meta
RoboCop 2 does not look great oh my God
all right [Music] simple CP is proud to present
the future of urban pacification RoboCop 2.
Urban pacification [__] [Music] [Laughter]
it rips his own head off that was hilarious
robots with emotional problems not robots
cyborgs this proves you need the human we use
living through human tissue and that's our whole
problems ampt big Tech nope finding themselves
stripped of all that is no wonder they become
our one success was a cop it's an Alex
Murphy top of his class devout Irish
Catholic Family Man indicates a fierce
sense of Duty that's probably what kept
Him alive the individual I believe that
Murphy's case was unusual but not unique
we can find someone else someone to whom the
prospect might even be desirable where can
you find a cop who's a devout Irish Catholic
I don't think they make a lot of Irish cows
don't check New Yorker bust [Music]
what a fascinating question would you only want
to Serve and Protect if you
were getting paid to do it
yes I mean it's a job I mean yeah okay I mean
I'm just saying why would it be a vigilante no
oh that's him that kid would grow up
to be Bon Jovi see my RoboCop movie he
would take him kill him and then turn him
into a robochild ah to replace his own One
Cop per car okay these are the roots
three cars one copper car that's right
did he really pay the man [Music] kid Kingpin
don't you should really count it you know
give him something to help him with his conscience
no that's right I don't really want it come on
Duffy I know you need it that's how he keeps him
keeps him addicted don't lose
me movie you got a problem
it's a very believable someone that's just real
me in until losing freeze turn around put your
hands up I'm gonna hold my gun up against you
for a while oh damn walk and then say freeze
that guy was probably the
stunt coordinator [Laughter]
oh hell no no John Belushi don't
[__] this up man it's all on you
have a seat where is Kane I
told you I don't know [Music]
arcade violence River Rouge the old sludge
plant you're a rotten cop [Music] Ghostbusters
see I feel like the production design
of the world the sets and stuff and the
paintings yeah I feel like it's like
a seven right now and I needed to go
to a 10. yep because the first one was a
ten just amp it up like I don't care if
it's neon or whatever if it looks like the
but this is doing it for you with a sticker
on the side that was peeling off like the
graffiti on the walls just amp it up yeah
this guy's whole Situation's amazing
this outfit this bolo tie combo don't
worry Murphy's lips are still intact not a scratch
how did he pull that off he somehow knew and
pushed the cut I don't I don't have answers
oh steel metal ground is not ideal for
robocops sneaking very stealthy clanks
they made this day a bit David
the small tune and Ant-Man playing
that role I think the kid's gonna
have a change of heart I hope so
I am a devout Roman Catholic
who loves rock and roll
that explains that guy's hair
though oh yeah no wait is that
Elvis yes so like the body of Elvis
I wasn't expecting Elvis like why
that are five one of us Must Die oh
he was just saying the question do
you want me dead or alive I thought
he was gonna yeah quote the tagline
[Music] it's like a clean
off [Music] man this kid's
oh [__] they program you and you do
it all right let me just try I forgive
you God I would love to be a cult
leader it seems simpler thank you
smart man
this is face to one's act
oh damn it's a small bruise
I wonder if the cop it's actually kind of sinister
I wonder if the cop like set
it up like that'd be great if
the cop because it is perfectly
designed to torture a Robocop
do they want to make Robocop their own
they say he's got a brain I want to
see it you think it was me that beat
you it was this are they gonna give
it to me addicted to drugs YouTube this drug
is not real it is made up it's called nuke
damn they're dismembering
RoboCop come on cut it out
I really do like how they're they are keeping
this menacing Vibe about what is his identity
they just threw body parts at the cops
oh my goodness Christ has been stripped
oh that is horrifying what a great
use of the animatronics I know every
support keeping the brain going
with micro shocks oh my God your
daughter Sue young is about to be kidnapped
this unit needs millions of dollars in
Parts you can't expect authorization for
that kind of cash outlay overnight you
don't fix him it's murder this movie is
surprising me I'm enjoying
more next especially yeah
oh no Double Cross by the criminals eh you
told them where we were oh it wasn't clever
you think you're the only cop we have how did
they know he told them maybe the kid heard it
I thought that woman was there like a cat
in a second it starts oh my God do not want
him doesn't he look scared oh
watch you learn you learn little boy [Music]
I have no use to society oh smart it's just about
the determination that is clever and messed up
they're gonna get their own evil anti-robo yeah
Robo murderer Robo criminal oh my God yes sequel
waiting for him way to go man now she
told her stick that Robo criminal onto you
[Music] bicep reboot I would not want to wake
up in this condition man cool prosthetic thing
it's horrifying he's critical
I've got to stay with him I'll
let you know when we need your services nobody
that is really well done though that is
horrifying it really is recommend program
like um visit an orphanage uh in the
first movie he was playing with kids and
saying stay in school uh um officer Alex Murphy
Detroit Police Department that won't do [Music]
RoboCop crime prevention unit I must learn
to lie I type it you think it you type it
I think it is it working or is she hacking him
you're free you're free from doubt free from
having to make painful choices yeah one-eyed
choice at school it's about Duality core the
dichotomy between dark and light yeah that is
an interesting question though I must ask myself
if I could just have it inputted into my brain
would I want that rather than the distance yeah
that smile's so unnerving ready for
Duty partner you're better let's go
he sounds terrific this is how imagine the
cartoon is I'm going to say something that
I feel like might be an unpopular opinion uh-oh
I think the script is better than the way this
movie is directed that's what I was saying
earlier I like the bones of it more than I
like how it's being executed so far I wonder if
the Irvine cursed it I don't know if he really
quite knew how to bring totally yeah yeah I'm
able to separate the script from the direction
and I'm like the script is pretty solid yeah I see
why Weller signed on yeah when he had it [Music]
I love this little league gang
wake up will ya good morning [Laughter]
hell yeah I need to talk with you I think
we should talk there are so many more kid
criminals in this it's amazing whether were they
still here a little bastards come up against the
wall let's go there's something about the nihilism
and the corruption of Innocence that I love the
intention of it and I think scripting wise if the
but the directing seems like it's holding back a
bit you know I feel like Paul verhoven should
have come back oh I would have loved that yeah
there's a perfect step harps
I'm having trouble [Laughter] that was
that was really cool having trouble think
of mom and dad what kind of lesson are
you teaching them a word on nutrition
[Applause]
the point is we all have to work
it's ocp they did something to you I'm fine this
movie is still so much better than I was led to
believe same I thought it's gonna be like a d this
is gonna be a terrible film yeah it was not like I
was like I didn't expect any of this seriously
some of the comedy is really well done too
oh my God there is so much beamable stuff here
yeah have I not seen memes of this yet [__]
thank you
thank you for not smoking [Music]
wow pool opinions for expressing yourself
holy [__] they put all this nonsense
into his brain he has to obey are you
are you prey as insulation
what is happening yeah what a total shift does he
know is he aware [Music] oh he's willing to risk
it he heard how to save himself [Music] there's
so much more electricity in this movie or trying
to mislead us into thinking he's unaliving himself
but he's actually trying to reboot his sister yeah
this whole movie is like that one
episode of all those Marvel Netflix
shows of just our superhero healing
gotta go through the Walkabout man
no directives foul he's back to being
Alex Murphy we'll offer our customers
the opportunity to control every aspect their
emotional lives blue velvet I think it's ready
sir yeah see there's some interesting topics
they're touching on like the corruption and
control of human emotion and that that controls
like consumerism there's there's so many things
that they're touching on that I think is
really interesting but they're touching on
so many and so quickly it's really like not as
thematically charged as the first because it's
like it's just not it's not as focused yeah but
it's still attempting stuff hey cops huh what cops
and they ain't carrying no ticket signs
they're going to kick somebody's ass
I love little moments like that in 80s and 90s
movies Side characters getting
their best guest star moments
great
[Music]
yo oh oh oh I thought his leg
was blown off okay nevermind
old school squibs all right who's
gonna kill this kid I think he's
just gonna get injured but I don't know
if he reforms he's done a lot of murder
the cops
[Music]
love some good practicality [Music]
yeah [Laughter]
oh my goodness oh that's a dope stun
that is a brave stunt like team that was
incredible bartender there especially yeah [Music]
fun sequence this is awesome oh [__] oh
the sound
Good Will of the seat oh nice take a bite
take off a bike gotta get on the bike
yes he needs a Lucius Fox he does he does oh
Robocop and a bike is as cool as that hoped
wanna play chicken you wanna get nuts can he
crash into it then fly through the window [Music]
I love that the plot device hole gave them a
better shot like that was so cleverly framed
oh yes he did he did did exactly what I was
hoping for 500 million in cash nuke money [Music]
's Kane who may not live the subject is
violently anti-social given to delusions of
godhood oh he's got to be the other RoboCop Robo
criminal's gonna be the big bad how did we not see
that even just now when they said he was almost
dead yeah we were bad movie viewers it was right
there the whole movie it's like one of the most
predictable platforms just on the nose I'm through
arguing with you and I'm not asking for your
permission Kane is in the hospital that we're
going to get I didn't realize you were a little
boy you physically can be overpowered you're you
know that's not fair [Music] it's not recording
you little bastard real bear ad acting
going on here when the movie's doing a
like an intentional comedy moment it's it's
funny it's good but this movie has a lot
of what just registers as unintentionally
funny yeah like this scene out of context
is hilarious why did we just cut out that
two minutes you're gonna have a chance for
immortality as long as nothing happens to
that lovely brain he's becoming the exact
thing he did not want to become I'm afraid
we lost our patient yep he just expired right
whoa that is so cold hold your
breath let's see the brain
show time we had it here it comes I don't
know about the rest of you I'm hungry [Music]
of what it looks like Mars Attacks so gross
it's a turn in my stomach a bit yeah yeah
I love that the POV of Robocop to this POV of like
evil and just seeing his own removed
face if you want honest government
to dig deep into your pockets
where does that put us Gilly
hello this is your honor very good news for you
the surprise look good they do someone's showing
up to bail the city out your services to ocp
will be rewarded we shifted 80 of our liquid
resources to the urban pacification plant and ocp
will plummet so will our stock I love the idea of
the urban pacification as a way to feign uh safety
and privatized city is terrifying as an idea yeah
if you want to you're not bringing up bringing
my lab I will do worse than get you fired now
leave me alone God you know man I really just feel
like it needed a better director and I like Empire
a lot like there's just a lack of fervor behind
the camera itself like it's kind of shot like a
TV movie and it's really buggy like a really well
done TV movie but you're not talking to screaming
well like back in the day TV movies like this
is him as a disembodied CGI monster like that
doesn't that doesn't work why not just keep his
face almost every frame just sort of feels like
a TV movie to me and it's I wouldn't if any of you
could help me I'm looking for a Mr Hopper how much
you need money I mean 37 million four hundred and
eighty thousand nine hundred and eleven dollars
guess you're in some pretty deep [__] well
you need all the help we can get young man he's
he's [__] let's get out of here [Music]
oh they're smart and they can control
privatizing the city for them [Music]
gentlemen well will 50 do
it terrible 80r [Laughter]
remotely close to being in sync there's been a
Robocop for a while oh yeah that's a good point
conscious or no we got Raptor claws for
some reason why why drugs people do drugs
because they want drugs nuke gives high quality
at a cheap price we don't go shoving our [__]
down anybody's throat and we don't advertise
it like they do with cigarettes or booze All
Things Considered little kid is not bad he's
not it's the way others act around him it's
always going to be a little cheesy just because
of context but he's not bad it's not him yeah
oh no the little boy's gonna get injured
Raptor evil RoboCop
oh no the mayor mayor's dead [Music] why
would you even try to shoot this thing okay
maybe maybe why would you try to shoot you know
you can't shoot RoboCop why would you treasure
[Music]
I guess one of the checklists of
a Robocop movie is shootouts in
manufacturing warehouse locations
we got this set we gotta use it
man this guy's been a tough
guy probably till he wasn't
Scorpion King face
he's just become there it is oh no
uh
[Music]
okay actor's doing the work
I'm just gonna give her credit
make love to it cold iron hand
it'll be great [Music] [__]
oh man oh man he's so mean to her whoa
where'd he go where has he been a small truck
why don't you just pretend to be dead
[Music]
Detroit [Music]
symbolism
what it's very subtle
innocence corrupted by greed nine-year-old Wall
Street boy surrounded by money that couldn't
save him I will call for a medical emergency unit
who did this it was Kane I'm gonna die you know
what that's like don't you it really sucks yeah
you don't know what he went through a few times
I think the most emotionally compelling part of
this movie was introduced so early on about his
wife and [__] and then I just I hate that
they just completely annihilated it's like
the 20-minute section plot points that could
be entire race yeah sorry folks video [Music]
what's this Nazi rally it's not a Nazi rally
what a black leather are they trying to make
it look like ah okay good there is
no hint it's been subtle throughout
telling you it's not what you
think guys magnificent structure
corporations human experimentation I don't
see any Nazis authoritarianism
privatizing entire city no degree
we're going to build a brand
new city for Detroit now status
an example to the world I love movies about
evil corporations that are produced by evil
corporations that's why I love the boys on Amazon
so makes the most profit the people who produce
the movie they know what they're doing you'll have
to tear down a lot of people's houses before you
can make that thing and take away their homes
every citizen will have a living unit nobody
elected you anyone can buy ocp stock and own a
piece of our city this is how we got to trumpism
come on 51 of our audiences man we
need a law enforcement unit capable
of meeting the enemy on his own
ground to get the job done [Music]
ladies and gentlemen towering
over the city a monolith RoboCop 2
made in America mean something again
how did he sneak it a hand Cannon and a Robocop a
hundred of these are produced every day RoboCop 2
will seek out every laboratory every dealer and
rid our city of Newton you know there's an addict
in there let's see how this goes it wasn't
just an attitude it was the head distributor
what's wrong with him it's nothing at all I turned
him off I can't Jane let's step outside [Music]
killer not even
[Music]
that controller is huge arms
this guy needs to stop creating cyborgs learn
come on guys going wrong it doesn't work out
oh [Music]
yeah [Music] the old Super Punch [Music]
cool Neko design you should smarts man yeah
[Music]
whoa that's a cool shot that's
actually kind of scary that was sad
yes 90s you need your climax to be
where our hero might fall to his
death mirroring the long-armed guy falling
in the first one you're coming with me okay
the hero's sacrifice
[Music]
oh whoa guys I can promise you that wasn't
a green screen was not no blackout lines
oh it's Duality and duplicitousness you see this
it's a humanoid versus the inhuman monstrosity of
man a lot about this movie has made me sad okay
I'm not gonna lie there's a lot of things that
just left me feeling like empty yeah there's a
lot I was really enjoyed about it but as it's
gone on it's it's Highs are high but it's lows
are low yeah yeah definitely a sequel ouch [Music]
Robot Chickens RoboCop too
guys everyone needs to evacuate the
city of Detroit perhaps leave Detroit
[Music]
that must have been a cool toy
battle ravaged RoboCop I feel
like they wanted to sell toys this time
yeah I mean look at that that's a toy
[Music]
this plant has gotten so awry [Music]
why even attempt
there you go clear the civilians
if you don't have like a a bazooka
this could look bad for ocp jobs [Music]
is he gonna OD the robot for a movie that
thematically sets up the question of soul
and Humanity this movie manages to lose
its Soul as it goes and like the opening
and end are so soulless like the bookends
are so like well this is what I was afraid
yeah it's really sad it's kind of cool
looking I suppose it's got lots of moments
see that was a cool shot the license
plates are barcodes yeah I like that
[Music]
wow Detroit is full of idiots foreign
[Music] the cops and Nazis have to
work together that's not until 2023.
[Music]
why did RoboCop go up that escalator
a thing to get the drugs okay
Association I didn't connect
the dots for a bit and I was
like what's where is he going I think that's why
[Music]
I thought that would do it I mean it wouldn't
take out RoboCop but I thought it was maybe if
I just drive this tank into this guy yeah bullets
won't do it let's give him what he wants [Music]
Target to memory that's clever
it's the Kardashian Coca-Cola ad
meth vocab [Music] I like how the scientist
lady's still hoping her robot will win yeah
I thought she might say behind
you or something [Music]
[Music]
plot is fine like Predator Judge
Dread movie ripped a lot of this
off oh my God oh my God the whole brain
and everything goodbye [Music] thank you
sweet [Music]
oh yeah stretch your back out it's good
unless RoboCop is three is so bad it's good I
have no interest in watching I agree this hurt
me a little bit yeah I've gotten so excited
such a roller coaster with this particular
one it's gone from like a minus to D minus
and back yeah this becomes like a void don't
be hard on yourself everything's going to be
all right we're talking about get right on it
this is like a great example of it being so on
the nose and heavy-handed and holding on too long
like that was not all her showing up and uh just
yeah it's like it doesn't get the direction and
script need to work together and like directors
work with their writers on rewriting and stuff
and I really think that and I also feel like
there's corporate input on this one we need toys
it just becomes like flat over that body
will ocp make reparations to the
victims it's just a problem for
me when a movie goes bigger but there's
less energy yeah you know patience Lewis
we're only human [Music]
I guess they didn't bring the wife back for the
third Act screenplay by Frank Miller Story by
Frank Miller so the story I did like and written
by Walton yeah whatever two written Buys in one
story by so maybe maybe Frank Miller and and uh
yeah my guess would be that Frank Miller wrote
this and then it brought in another guy to change
it up rewrite the work of Frank Miller and I feel
like Frank Miller and verhoven could have made a
hell of a Robocop too yeah yeah alrighty guys well
hey uh now that we're in the review portion I want
to say that if you're here um I've been watching
appreciate it but we're also on like apple and
Spotify and so if you're listening to this on the
podcast formula real rejects please though what do
you do on podcasts you like that I like it you can
leave a review rate it rate it all do it all and
also while we're here I want to say thank you to
all I've been buying some a real rejects apparel
I'm wearing right right now I think an appropriate
thing to wear for a thing about you know
corporations and consumerism is who influences
the influencers with my little boy Rorschach right
now but we also got a whole bunch of other teas
that is an amazing way to support the channel
and yeah yeah so thank you all for listening
hoy alrighty well if you watch the reaction
I think you'll see that we were rarely open
my okay we had a journey basic journey of
my emotional Journey with this started off
cheesy and I went all right it's cheesy I see the
problems but I feel like it's gonna be a fun time
then I was going oh wait this movie's actually a
lot smarter than I expected there's actually some
depth to this they're making some interesting
choices in commentary and emotional decisions
then it started a bob and weave it's wrapping it
all up adding new stuff sprinkling speeding yeah
and then by the time we got to which you can
only describe as like a Marvel for now where
uh or a comic book movie finale which is kind
of appropriate for a comic book writer to have
done this um it the lasting impression that
it left me with was wow this movie has lost
its soul and I'm not sure exactly what point it
was but it it reached some point where I realized
when was it when can I pinpoint one I think it was
when we had lost Robin Wright order was this known
if that's Robin right um there's a good chunk when
we didn't have RoboCop right I was gonna say I
think when we lost RoboCop I realized they weren't
gonna wrap it up in a way that was gonna feel
fulfilling and then once RoboCop came back it was
just action RoboCop return it was just the first
half the First Act and the the second half the
third act were soulless and the middle was solid
but I do think that second half the third Act
was like okay I mean the First Act was at least
a little fun yeah but I think it was just being
back in robocopic but this movie didn't I to me
and maybe you guys love the the finale and had
fun with it I personally did not I thought that
it was it started to become really I just felt
numb and it was long if yeah this movie felt
[__] long like whenever whenever they'd hold
on all the action I was like okay it dragged it
started to drag which is insane because there
are so many 20-minute sections that introduce
really interesting themes and Concepts and they'd
rush through those and then the action would be
really long and heavy-handed and then they'd
like undermine some of the ideas they'd set up
and rush to the next thing but then it still
felt long it was weird they didn't it wasn't
even that the execution itself was getting rushed
it was the wrap up to it that was yeah it was it
would set you up like oh we're gonna spend some
time here oh it's over yeah that's where it kept
sort of going these in these strange increments
um okay like I loved this setup with him and his
wife which is not come around I really thought
third act would bring her back and it didn't
because he essentially goes on the same character
Arc yeah that he went on in the first one which
is rediscovering I am human you know it's the
same it's the same character art it didn't do
anything different and I thought they could have
explored his place of identity here and how much
of him was human how much he still felt like
himself because I thought that was the setup at
the end of the first movie is like he's found who
he is but now he needs to accept him as Robocop
and that's what I thought the second movie was
gonna be yeah and it seemed like that's what
they were setting up here and then they didn't
and they they just did not go through with that
um like the scene with him and his wife I
thought was an extremely compelling scene
um and and then the the the world I think the
world of um nuke and it's not fair to compare
it but it is the only thing I got on my on
my mind right now I think the world of nuke
needed the touch of a movie that came out decades
later dread which red did with slow-mo of this is
really controlling the the world this is how
the criminals Dominate and they kind of did
like talking about it but I didn't feel the
world this time it was just Exposition with
another that was a big missing ingredient for me
was and I was trying to touch on that and figure
it out as the movie went the first one I felt
the world I didn't feel like this was lived in
um it seemed very surface and trying to be
this is exactly 1990 wow so yeah we said
transition for 80s and 90s they filmed this in 89
it came out in 90. okay so it's exactly that wow
um yeah so uh but when they started like tear him
open and and strip him down to pieces I was like
wow what a compelling concept because and you they
set it up it's not just I don't think it's us just
being this is the movie I I didn't know there's
not no version of this movie that I wish it would
be something yeah we thought of 10 different
things that we would have gone with that plot
Point yeah and then we'd go like okay we're here
now let's go this way with what what could be and
then it kept just abandoning the interesting one
yeah because you got the the cops on strike yep
um which is an interesting world to set up of
how the the uh what was it called Omni core
Omni takeover on privatize the city yes they're
controlling it they're paying to keep the cops on
strike like that was smart smart Ingenuity and a
great a great follow-up from the first one since
the cops and the first one were saying we should
go on strike and yeah we set it up they're going
like okay perfect great sequel setup and then
RoboCop the one hope for law enforcement is now
torn apart and that mistake so you can fight
a human like we display it on the cops who
are fighting for their rights yeah you know like
oh this is hopeless for them we had five minutes
with that they were like yeah and then he's back
did they reprogram him and oh they've they've took
complete control over him and made him not at all
what he is designed to be and that's like half
an act like that was like 15 minutes it's like
maybe 15 minutes and it's funny but interesting
and oh this is very very different and what and
as they're building some other Sinister machine
and then they just can it yeah it really it's
a really it really starts to bum you out and
the commentary on like controlling drugs and the
the world that Frank Miller does so well which
definitely it's funny when I watch Robocop one I
kept thinking like man I bet Frank Miller loved
this I think we even talked about it yeah and then
this one being written Frank Miller found feels a
lot like his Dark Knight Returns with you know
the the bad guys running the town and even the
shadowy figure talking like all that stuff is very
Frank Miller but they don't let you live in the
world enough with that I think the idea was that
opening would show you like this lady beats up
an old lady this goes over here these girls take
this and like that's not enough like so it never
felt like there was actually Stakes with the world
that then they have to refer back to yes oh yeah
man like and kidpin like he worked sometimes and
wasn't the actor oh I wish I looked I forgot to
look at the kids actor's name I'm wondering if he
did anything else but like the kid pin worked but
it was just hard to see the actors acting around
it because sometimes it like plausible deniability
went away sometimes suspensional disbelief it
went away also the mayor was like sometimes
in a totally different movie with how big his
performance was and his performance was like
this big big eccentric thing that almost felt like
the satire that verhoven does so well but then the
kid was so like in this grounded Zone it was just
really tricky I don't think Irvin kirschner and me
and maybe some of this has something to do with
the writing itself I don't think the handle of
because the first movie had such a great balance
of satire without becoming spoof or parody Or
feeling corny or goofy like it knew how to be
it like the first one's like Practically Perfect
um with knowing how to be all these elements
and then also take it seriously and then find
it intense and be emotionally gripped and I was
I can't say I was ever once emotionally gripped
by anything that happened in this movie the the
one part where I thought I might be was the thing
with the with the wife and but then after I was
never great I'd go into modes where I was very
interested or I thought like oh this is thought
provoking or I'm appreciative of what their
talking about right now and there's some cool
set pieces I like the I really actually like
the one where RoboCop is on the truck yeah that
was really well done and the set piece where he's
like dismembered and they're walking him through
the police station I was the closest I was to
emotionally invested I was like where because I
care about RoboCop and Peter Weller does such a
good job him disassembled I was like totally
invested oh yeah that was where I was like oh
and then like that was the thing I think they
abandoned quickest and then I was like briefly
very invested in the idea of like controlling the
drug narrative and like fueling a city by making
it like we're gonna have we're gonna be 100 of
this and the mayor being like Oh I guess that
kind of works that was a fascinating plot point
and then they abandoned that immediately the kid
died like three minutes later yeah but there's so
many moments that were almost almost yeah this is
like this is very much the the potential movie
yeah yeah this is one of the biggest examples of
a sequel going right and wrong simultaneously that
I've seen in a long time like when people used to
talk about sequels never working this is a great
example of like oh so close I genuinely mean it I
think Peter Weller is Sensational he really helps
Elevate this movie yeah the performance he gives
is RoboCop I think is people talk about you know
that term criminally underrated and I think Peter
well honestly I I feel like him as a performer
as Alex Murphy yeah is a very very underrated
because it's a role that's easy to write off as
you just got to pretend it's like when people
like I'll give it to you if you talk about like
and I don't agree with it I'll give it to you
if you talk about like Arnold Schwarzenegger it's
like a Terminator right it's a very specific kind
of performance here Peter Weller knows how to
bring death to this character and the and the
struggle with uh the the emotional development of
Man vs machine all happening internally I think
it's excellent and I feel like anytime he's on
screen it's because of Peter Weller knowing how to
that it's it's the same thing of what Carl Urban
had to learn how to do and not the same thing but
but similar where you're not going to see this
guy's eyes or or when he's climbing like he's
literally got like less than Cyclops face he's
got nothing in like a lot of communication is
body language and tone and he found a way to do
that with this one and and uh at the last one
and the comedy and just changing how he presents
his mouth when they when they reprogrammed him
was genius like that was such impressive acting
because obviously it was played for laughs but
even when he wasn't speaking his mouth was being
carried in a different way in his body language
like that's incredible and I was also really
impressed that there's only one flashback I
think a lesser film would have had way more
flashbacks to him pre-robocop you see him as
him once right right and I think the I I like the
I like how they they put the pedal to the metal
here on the the capitalism side of things yes
and and carrying over our people from the last
movie uh which something 80s and 90s did great I
always that's one of my favorite things about the
Lethal Weapon movies is that each of the Lethal
Weapon movies has the same group of cops so when
like you lose them in the third one you're really
invested in like you've lived with those cops it's
not just the leads it's like the whole family
yeah and I think that 80s and 90s movies did a
lot better job making uh a series feel coherent
and this felt like that where like we see the
same cops come back we're invested in those
characters too well the the corporation people
too I think bringing them back and watch I I like
the idea that's what I mean like I don't feel like
this movie was void of ideas because it wasn't
too many ideas yeah I think so because nothing
really gotta meet its potential its full potential
enough nothing here gotta meet its full potential
um and I did not come into this movie one and
I hate it I actually I came and just thought
it might be fun like I thought it might be a fun
bad move I thought it was gonna be more like the
first dread where it's like this is fun because
it's like well this is whatever it is and then
when it got good I was actually more bummed when
it regressed yeah like if this had stayed I didn't
expect any good yeah like if that's it this is
state of C I'd be like well I heard it's like
a d or enough so I'm happy but when this like
touched that a minus point and then dropped to
a d That's way more of like a come on like I'm
tired yeah no no that that bummed me it bummed
me out by the time we got there um and then the
last 20 minutes 17 or so minutes when it's just
like all right it's an action movie I'm like
but your RoboCop isn't like that was my when
we watched the first one we both kept saying like
I can't believe this isn't just an action book no
it felt like it became perfunctory with it because
I thought there was an again like oh interesting
this guy who the cult leader dude what's his name
oh it's a cane Lake I think like okay did you say
something about Han Solo I think it's like a Cain
and Abel thing I'm guessing some oh it's because
you uh uh Arnold oh arnim Zola yeah that's why
you said that's what I was thinking of that yeah
oh but he definitely had that Vibe which is also a
very Frank Miller That's kaneki okay yeah when he
cause he's the one who dismembers or instructs
the dismemberment of Robocop which I love the
body horror again to that moment and he um
he's the one you know preaching about the the
philosophical understandings of what they've done
to this guy yeah you know so I loved him turning
into this monster he didn't see it so clearly
telegraphed was so great I think I think him
turning into that like oh that Sinister to do and
like haha you know it it can work on a multi-layer
yeah and I even like the goofiness of like his
brain in his eyes yeah like I thought that was fun
um but it's just nothing he's just nothing he's
just a it's it actually I think is it makes him
less threatening when it's just it like at
209 is more imposing yeah even though this
thing is like a super Advanced hyper thing um
and and they're telling us there's a there's a
brain in this one yeah I I felt it was more of
an empty vessel Scorpion King face didn't help
oh that was something else man it's like
lawnmower man yeah that was that was bad
hello so much work but a lot more yeah yeah I
think this is like a c for me the last the last I
want to say like 40 minutes really started to turn
me off yeah it was it it was very there's solid
hour here that I really enjoy this was like almost
almost two hours and there's a solid hour here
or close to an hour I really don't really have
much issue with the first like I was like yeah
I mean comparatively there's stuff I'm big as
a big of a fan of but yeah there was like a
like maybe like 45 minutes I I really really
really enjoyed some stuff I I kind of loved
um the music was good and solid there was
sometimes it was really tonally inappropriate
that like sometimes the the beautiful score of
Robocop was used in a way that like felt like a
satire that wasn't meant to be there were a couple
times he was like doing something I was like this
is heroic you know I okay I heard it's funny I
I've I heard Irvin kirschner was not like really
the director of Empires I've heard that too but
I don't remember who I've heard that like George
Lucas actually was or who actually I like George
Lucas would like kind of step back yeah or was the
Return of the Jedi I might have been both um and
I heard Irvin kirschner this was the last movie
he directed and he's only done TV since wow which
is fitting to me because it's felt shot third TV
it felt flat in the world oh just the lighting
and the framing there there was no real distinct
Voice or style it it it it really felt like made
for TV in the way it would like made for TV on a
bigger budget yeah you know and serviceable there
was nothing really cool about the way it was shot
like that was something that surprised me about
the first one was oh wow there's a there's a
there's a really great framing yeah there's a lot
of language in the first one it's just imagery
which I loved that first movie is so exceptional
I I really can't get over how good that first
movie was but the the pace to this I don't like
I don't like the pacing um especially in the last
40 minutes the the energy I feel like is void
there's no fervor to the direction here uh I I
gotta say like I think a lot actually fell on the
way this movie was directed and I have to look up
right now if there was something that went
wrong yeah I was so curious I'm gonna read
the Reddit immediately and get on like Wikipedia
is there behind the scenes drama I really want to
look it up koi do you mind let's do it I'm very
curious too because like halfway through I was
like what a hodgepodge of things what this [__]
happened to here also the relationship with uh
his partner just was uh didn't care another
vessel what went wrong with the RoboCop 2.
um I okay what did Joe Blow say all right other
than oh Jesus is such a small pond hold on a
second guys we will get you that we will get you
uh again see they're they're blaming the screen
but that's part of why you disagree that's part
of where you get and like I feel like half baked
unfinished ideas there were things that needed
more fleshing out I I agreed because there were
so many interesting things like the script is by
no means perfect and definitely needed another
pass but I'm like I don't feel like this that's
the shitty thing about being a writer wow look
at the difference in box office today versus then
highest grossing movie on 14.1 million during its
opening weekend that's insane how different box
office expectations are and the tickets were like
three dollars okay hold on a sec what were the
behind the scenes problems with a robocopter I'm
just gonna get very specific here let me see if
I can find something yeah I'm really curious like
what developed over time and how much has been
revealed because like I feel like this is a lot
of inside baseball but now that we've entered that
four decades mark okay so he declined to return
for the secret um okay kirschner's vision for the
film was at all which we talked about I felt like
the entire thing was at odds uh the producers so
again exactly exactly exactly what we said during
the reaction was that it felt there was corporate
input yes more action so they wanted it to make
it a more action-oriented film the producers
and less satirical film than the original and
we were just saying how they did not know how
to capture the satire which is what makes the
first movie so special okay the rush production
looks like Rush schedule okay uh I just gave
the production very little time to work you feel
that Peter Weller wasn't happy with the script in
film's Direction he clashed with kirschner on set
again called it the direction I could understand
the script but the part of a director's job when
selling the vision is to work with your writers
on it yeah you know I'm saying the script's not
perfect but that is that is an integral piece
um okay it was a success or uh unhappy star poor
special effects okay so I didn't
know if it was just poor because
it was it was uh realized as that see I can't see
this as it can't be classic no it's not quite to
in either direction yeah because it did it did
not reach the it never quite reached the point
of so like there was a a moment here or there that
was Ah that's so cheesy it's yeah it's fun but the
ca some people view it as it can't be classic and
to me I'm like nah this just became it took itself
too serious yeah satire was needed yeah I know man
that was that that 102 million worldwide that's
a crazy different bar everything we suspected it
would literally spelled out it was like okay yeah
those things totally happened yeah it's it's
on screen that's so interesting you can feel
it from the vibe but yeah movies aren't emotional
going experience No Matter What observations one
might have it's all it always comes down to what
are you feeling in your heart and the emotion it
conveyed was all the things I suspected went
wrong with this yeah this is people bearing
their souls that's what art is and this definitely
felt like it was a hundred people with different
perspectives going like and the irony of of a
movie that starts out thematically about the
question of what is a soul to them become such a
soulless experience too many corporate interests
might override the humanity of a situation making
it more difficult like the movie did is that's
the strangest part about it you know is that's
what the movie's trying to talk about and then
you got the producer something and be like you
can't do that take that apart take it rebuild it
make it less and obviously call that RoboCop 2 in
the movie was clever but now in our life RoboCop
2 being the thing they built and then and I can
imagine for Peter Weller it's is conflicting like
when you're the director you got to orchestrate
this sure kind of thing and then you got
you got to conduct the set but then you got like
the producers and the studio people above you who
are giving you orders and you gotta paying for
it and you got to conduct yeah and then and then
of course you're gonna clash with your actor yeah
of course you're going to do that because you're
like you can't satisfy both yeah especially if
you're changing the tone on the sequel that he
clearly loved in the first yeah I feel like Irvin
kirschner wanted to probably make a better film
than this yeah yeah and like a better action movie
and I think Peter Weller probably would make a sad
talk because there's a lot of that in the script
oh man well that was an interesting Journey y'all
uh glad to have seen it though overall very glad
to have you ever watched yeah I really enjoyed it
like that was a good journey I'm like not gonna
watch it again but I'm glad to have like gone
through that experience RoboCop one I will I will
watch it unless RoboCop three is like okay this is
so bad that it's enjoyable I mean I honestly feel
like we just go to the reboot if we're making that
decision because if we're gonna go so bad it's bad
instead of reboots not that bad I like what's his
name kinnamon I heard it's like very serious yeah
but because I mean that first one's so special
I think I've seen it I just don't remember that
is not a good sign that it's not that bad hey man
there's a Whole Decade Greg just missed I have
I have that memory problem yeah I mean it's good
for us because positive but I can't tell you
anything that specifically goes down in that
there's a lot of 80s and 70s I missed and Greg
missed the 2000s by way of being a little toasty
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm pretty confident I saw
it at least once yeah I'm very intrigued well
let us know in the comments what you want us to
dive into next I'd rather enjoy these 80s action
movie adventures with Greg but uh we are now we
just did a 1991 but this whole tone I'm really
about so let us know in the comments anything
you want us to check out please do like share
subscribe hit that notification all the things and
we will see you very soon much love rejection whoa
oh we should have someone out shout something
out Michael Linden I'm gonna look up real fast
this guy's from Sweden he's from Sweden okay and
uh I feel like Sweden is in need of a Robocop so
Mikhail here's what we gotta do we've got to
get you killed first oh and and then we have
to turn your body into that of a cybernetic
I'm trying to type a whole different question
what is the crime rate in Sweden and then uh
we gotta turn you my friend into a cybernetic
organism design only for saving only for savings
and then because right now let's see here
um in 2022 in uh out of a hundred thousand uh
inhabitants the crime rate was out of only 15
000 most of that being uh theft drug related
offenses and robbery lack of murder though so
I mean they got health insurance this side rate
is low we die easier here because we got a lot
of things where you can't save most crime rates
are non-violent and that would be the Dilemma for
your people of Sweden just assess assess RoboCop
people will be like we don't need this RoboCop
Stockholm it's higher so we'd go there but then
still be like bro it's just like a petty drug
charge what are you doing RoboCop we don't need
you to be shooting us can't imagine he's cheap
to run it would not be cheap it would probably run
the Country Dry I mean I imagine it's like nuclear
or something I think we would probably make Bank
corruption with the economy would be in complete
disarray just shambles because that's a very
small population in general your fault and people
would blame you you would not be making Sweden
better no no you'd be the bad guy in RoboCop
in fact this was all horrible idea and I don't
know why you agree to it you did poor writing
versus Studio interference is what happened
as per RoboCop too and in this case we're both
but we appreciate you being a patron well we
Sully your country with our bad idea that's the
American way that's what we do we're gonna invade
we're gonna colonize we're gonna make bad ideas
we're gonna pretend it wasn't us we're gonna get
out of there yeah Sweden Sweden foreign [Music]